on the mount tonight for the tribe
right-hander carlos carrasco in his
career he's two-and-oh and two starts
against the brewers
strong on a miss he struck him out
that was a nice change up and a perfect
time and opportunity to throw it
got him looking
came back with that slider and that one
just nicked the outside edge
much to the dismay of jed
jerko two down no score payoff pitch and
a swing and a miss split change in the
dirt first two guys get on the next
three strike out here comes corbin burns
1-0 and a sparkling era in the mid twos
if he was playing third base it'd be
even better there's a driver deep center
field gamble's way over his head short
hops the wall on his way to second base
with another double is cesar hernandez
that is number 13 on the year
and that is the eighth time in his last
17 games that he's had at least one
double here's chase peterson and it's
two and two
swinging a miss another strikeout for
cookie that gives him
four
already in the first seven hitters
here's the 3-2
swing and a miss
down to chase
pits out of the zone
long battle with reyes at the plate
justin
walked his first time up
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a changeup
and five k's for carrasco
here's austin hedges the catcher
one 155 on the season
hedges can't hold up another strikeout
for corbin burns
one two called strike three
three strikeouts in three innings
for corbin burns
so a big early moment for the crew right
here a 0-0 ball game base is loaded and
two away and luis uria is coming to the
plate
and a slow bouncer it's going to die in
the infield grass and the brewers will
take the lead thank you very much
yeah riaz with the big swing a rolling
bun down the third baseline jerk wave to
score easily
jacob nottingham is loaded
ground ball two-win door he'll go to
hernandez for the ending ending force
jose ramirez to lead off here in the
fourth inning
all in two strikes and another strikeout
for corbin burns pulled the string at
beauty
well he's something else i mean he's on
a roll right now three balls
and two strikes now on the first baseman
for cleveland
colts strike three and burns another one
two three inning
one ball and two strikes to count on
hira
inside out swing but he crunches his bat
and what a play by hernandez as they
turn to double play
camel couldn't put the brakes on and get
out of the way of hernandez they always
say don't get tagged out
try to get in a rundown if you can but
he just ran himself right into cesar
got him looking yelich doesn't like it
he's out to end the fifth six k's for
carresco so it's gonna be bases loaded
nobody out here's austin hedges struck
out back in the third
big o two pitch swing and a miss
about that three sliders to get them
on strikes and that's a big first down
now here's delano to shields
to third they come home they get the
force there
and the throw hits the shields coming
around third with the tying run is tyler
nathan
and in the third with the go ahead run
is josh naylor so it'll be a fielder's
choice
reyes is retired at home
but naquin alertly when he saw the ball
hit the line on the shields he just kept
coming around third and he scores
orlando arcia the right-handed hitting
shortstop
now the indians bullpen is busy as arcia
swings and misses at a change up in the
dirt
the pitch swung on lifted in the air to
left routine for naylor he's camped
under it and he'll make the catch and
maybe all for carrasco
he'll leave after six innings having
made 97 pitches corbin burns back out
there for the sixth inning
looking low and away the 3-2 he chased
it
fastball off the plate and lindor
strikes out the seventh strikeout for
corbin burns nottingham sets up outside
and a chopper a high one burns
and he'll make the play
a one two three sixth inning for corbin
burns
one down here in the seventh and here
swings at that first pitch right field
back to the wall off the wall
and the brewers are going to take the
lead
maria scores wow
and milwaukee out in front two to one as
kesten hira comes through
christian yelich
will face the veteran oliver perez
[Applause]
village pounds went into the ground and
it's misplayed and the brewers are going
to score two runs and yelich on his way
to second base how about that we're
talking about their defense all night
how good it has been
it looked like santana wanted to make a
throw to home plate just forgot about
catching the baseball ryan braun
will be the pinch hitter
and right up the middle base hit
here comes yelich
and milwaukee has another one and it's
5-1 as braun comes through with the
pinch-hit rbi single
kira had that double back in the seventh
inning 3-0 pitch
swinging a high fly
deep left field on a 3-0 pitch kesten
hira goes deep
a two-run shot for home run number 10.
how about that quick battling a fast
the brewers putting up some numbers
tonight against a really good pitching
staff
two way for fran mill reyes who has
walked twice and struck out
and a little nubbler gonna be a tough
play the flip claudio got him
nice play out there by matthias to
claudio to close it out
and the brewers win this one seven to
one